.
Bakterien sind überall.
Jetzt, in diesem Moment,
wuseln Millionen von Bakterien
auf deiner Zunge herum.
Viele davon sind harmlos.
Einige sogar wichtig.
Ohne unsere Darmbakterien z.B.
würde unsere Verdauung
nicht so gut funktionieren.
Aber natürlich
gibt es auch böse Bakterien.
Keime, Krankheitserreger. Und manche
davon werden immer furchterregender.
Was sind resistente Keime überhaupt?
Was richten sie an?
Und warum
sind auch wir selbst daran schuld?
Das klären wir jetzt.
* Titelmelodie *
Fangen wir an mit den Basics.
Bakterien sind winzigkleine Zellen,
die alles fressen,
was nicht bei 3 auf den Bäumen ist.
Wobei, das kann man nicht sagen.
Bäume fressen sie auch.
Z.B. sorgen sie dafür,
dass tote Pflanzen oder Tiere
wieder zu Erde werden.
Indem sie sie aufessen.
Da gibt es ganz viele faszinierende
YouTube-Videos.
Also ziemlich grauenvoll, aber...
- Eichhörnchen! - auch faszinierend.
Damit uns so etwas
nicht bei lebendigem Leibe passiert,
haben wir ein Immunsystem,
das alle Bakterien plattmacht,
die es wagen, an uns zu knabbern.
Danke Immunsystem!
Aber jetzt gibt es
ja noch die Evolution.
Im Laufe der Evolution
spezialisieren sich Lebewesen.
Sie entwickeln Skills,
durch die sie sich
mit relativ wenig Konkurrenz
in ihren jeweiligen Nischen
ausbreiten und durchsetzen können.
Und so gibt es Bakterien,
die sich darauf spezialisiert haben,
unser Immunsystem zu umgehen, um uns
doch ein bisschen anzuknabbern.
Wenn man so will.
Solche bakteriellen Krankheiten
plagen uns Menschen
schon seit es uns gibt.
Von der Pest,
die in Europa im 14.Jh.
ein Drittel
der gesamten Bevölkerung dahinraffte,
über Syphilis bis zur Entzündung
durch eine Schramme an der Hand.
Oder durch einen eingewachsenen
Zehnagel, das mit Pech
zu einer Blutvergiftung wurde,
wodurch man dann starb.
Ja, eine Schramme
war lebensgefährlich.
Für alle, die sagen,
dass früher alles besser war.
Aber Wissenschaft und Medizin
brachte uns eine wichtige Waffe
gegen Bakterien.
Alles fing an mit der Erkenntnis,
dass es überhaupt Bakterien gibt.
Wie diese Erkenntnis kam
dann auch die Einführung der Hygiene.
Und Mitte des 20. Jahrhunderts
kamen dann die:
Der Clou: Antibiotika
sind hochgiftig für Bakterien,
aber harmlos für Menschen.
Denn Bakterien und Menschen
sind ja zum Glück verschieden genug.
Und Antibiotika
greifen bestimmte Stoffwechselwege
oder bestimmte Strukturen an,
die wir Menschen gar nicht haben,
die für Bakterien
aber überlebensnotwendig sind.
Z.B. haben Bakterien eine Zellwand,
die angegriffen werden kann durch
Antibiotika wie z.B. Penicillin.
Penicillin hemmt ein Protein,
das die Bakterien
zum Aufbau der Zellwand brauchen.
Jedes Mal, wenn Bakterien
sich teilen und somit vermehren,
müssen sie
eine neue Zellwand aufbauen.
Ohne das ansprechende Protein
baut sich aber keine Zellwand auf
und die Bakterien laufen bei dem
Versuch, sich zu teilen, einfach aus.
Das ist nur ein Beispiel. Es gibt
viele verschiedene Antibiotika,
die Bakterien das Leben
auf viele verschiedene
Arten und Weisen schwermachen.
Dank Antibiotika
war es nun kein Problem mehr,
einen Kratzer zu bekommen.
Und tödliche Krankheiten wie Syphilis
konnten nun
ganz einfach behandelt werden.
Antibiotika killen also Bakterien.
Aber:
- Das Leben findet einen Weg.
- Denn jetzt passiert das,
was in der Evolution passieren muss.
Leben bedeutet Vermehrung,
Fortpflanzung.
Dabei werden jedes Mal Gene kopiert.
Doch beim Kopieren
entstehen kleine Kopierfehlerchen,
also kleine Veränderungen
in der Gensequenz, sogenannte:
Durch diese Mutationen
können sich Lebewesen mit der Zeit
an ihre Umgebung anpassen.
Also die vorteilhaften Mutationen
setzen sich durch,
werden weitergegeben.
Und durch diese Mutationen
können sich Lebewesen
auch an Veränderungen
in der Umgebung anpassen.
Z.B.,
haben wir gerade drüber gesprochen,
greift Penicillin
ein ganz bestimmtes Protein an,
nämlich das "Zellwand-Protein".
Was, wenn jetzt
durch so eine Mutation
genau dieses Zellwand-Protein
verändert wird.
Und zwar so, dass es
weiterhin Zellwände aufbauen kann,
aber nicht mehr durch das
Antibiotikum angegriffen werden kann.
Dann, Freunde der Sonne,
haben wir den Salat,
dann hat sich nämlich eine sogenannte
Antibiotika-Resistenz entwickelt.
Das Antibiotikum wirkt nicht mehr.
Das Bakterium überlebt, vermehrt sich
und gibt diese Gensequenz weiter.
Wie erschreckend gut
das funktioniert,
sehen wir in diesem Experiment
der Harvard Medical School.
Die Forscher bauten hier
eine Art tödlichen Hindernisparcours
für Bakterien auf.
Ein 1,2 m langes Feld,
das sie in mehrere Zonen auftreten.
Links und rechts außen
bakterienfreundliche Zonen:
super Nährboden,
gute Bedingungen zum Vermehren.
Ein Streifen weiter innen jeweils
war der Boden
mit einem Antibiotikum verseucht.
Und zwar in der gerade so
tödlichen Dosis für diese Bakterien.
Ein Streifen weiter
innen dasselbe Antibiotikum,
aber zehnfach höher dosiert.
Dann weiter
hundertfach höher dosiert und
in der Mitte die tausendfache
Konzentration des Bakteriengifts.
Was passiert jetzt,
wenn man von rechts und links
Bakterien auf dieses Feld loslässt?
Zuerst besiedeln die Bakterien
nur die äußeren Streifen.
Das Antibiotikum
verhindert weitere Ausbreitung.
Doch dann: Die erste erfolgreiche
Mutation erobert das vergiftete Feld.
Die Bakterien
breiten sich weiter aus.
Bei jedem neuen Streifen
kommt es zu einem kurzen Stopp.
Aber es dauert nicht lange,
bis sich weitere Mutationen bilden,
mit denen die Bakterien am Ende
selbst die tausendfache Konzentration
des Antibiotikums überleben.
Und das Ganze
nach gerade mal 11 Tagen.
Je mehr Mutationen Bakterien
nacheinander durchlaufen,
desto stärkere Resistenzen
können sie ausbilden.
Dieses faszinierende und gleichzeitig
erschreckende Experiment zeigt uns,
dass wir mit Antibiotika
Resistenzen quasi heranzüchten.
Da sich Bakterien
viel schneller vermehren als wir,
können sie sich auch
viel schneller revolutionär anpassen.
Und es kommt noch schlimmer.
Es gibt nämlich noch:
Also Bakterien brauchen keinen Sex,
um sich fortpflanzen,
weil sie sich einfach nur teilen.
Aber sie haben
einen speziellen Trick auf Lager:
Sie können DNA-Pakete austauschen.
Und weil dadurch, genau wie beim Sex,
Erdinformationen ausgetauscht werden,
nennt man das auch Bakterien-Sex.
Dadurch können sie
in Windeseile Rezepte austauschen,
die sie resistent
gegen Antibiotika machen.
Und jetzt Pass auf:
Im Gegensatz zum normalen Sex
funktioniert das auch
zwischen Bakterienarten.
D.h., Resistenzen können sich
von Bakterienart zu Bakterienart
übertragen.
Auch unsere freundlichen
Darmbakterien
können Resistenzen
auf Krankheitserreger übertragen.
Und nur damit das klar ist:
Einige dieser Resistenz-Rezepte
sind schon Millionen von Jahre alt.
Denn viele dieser Antibiotika
haben wir ja nicht entwickelt
oder erfunden, sondern nur entdeckt.
Das sind Substanzen,
die von Mikroorganismen schon seit
Millionen von Jahren benutzt werden,
um gegeneinander Krieg zu führen.
Resistenzentwicklung ist
eine natürliche Folge der Evolution.
Und je mehr Antibiotika
wir verwenden,
desto schneller und öfter
entwickeln sich Resistenzen.
Und das Problem ist größer,
als man denkt.
Antibiotika werden nicht nur
bei Krankheiten verabreicht.
Bei Organtransplantationen
oder Kaiserschnitten
kommen sie zum Einsatz.
Krebspatienten bekommen Antibiotika,
begleitend zur Chemotherapie.
Weil sie ihr Immunsystem schwächt.
In Krankenhäusern kommen nicht nur
viele verschiedene Krankheitserreger
zusammen, sondern
auch viele verschiedene Antibiotika.
Das ist ein wahres
Erreger-Trainingslager.
Auch die Landwirtschaft
setzt Antibiotika ein.
Und wenn 1 er krank wird,
wird oft die ganze Herde behandelt.
Weil die Ansteckungsgefahr
auf kleinem Raum sehr hoch ist.
Klar ist: Wir können
nicht auf Antibiotika verzichten
und uns sämtlichen Krankheiten
hingeben.
Ein Rückfall in ein vorantibiotisches
Zeitalter wäre grausam.
Es würde viele,
viele Menschenleben kosten.
Aber jetzt übertreiben wir es
ein bisschen mit den Antibiotika.
Laut Erhebungen
verschiedener Krankenkassen
werden von niedergelassenen Ärzten
viel zu häufig
Antibiotika verschrieben,
die nicht notwendig sind.
Z.B. bei Erkältungen.
Die werden nämlich
meistens von Viren verursacht,
wogegen Antibiotika
völlig wirkungslos sind.
Weil die ja
nur gegen Bakterien helfen.
Dann gibt es Probleme
mit sogenannten:
Das sind Antibiotika,
die nur als zweite Wahl
oder nur bei bestimmten Krankheiten
eingesetzt werden sollen.
Quasi wenn es nicht anders geht.
Reserveantibiotika haben entweder
sehr starke Nebenwirkungen
oder ein besonders hohes Risiko
für Resistenz-Bildung.
Oder oft werden neue Antibiotika
vorsichtshalber
auf die Reserveliste gestellt,
um Resistenz-Bildung
möglichst lange hinauszuzögern.
Doch leider werden Reserveantibiotika
auch viel zu häufig verschrieben.
Ein tragisches Beispiel
ist die Antibiotika-Klasse
der sog. Fluorchinolone.
Fluorchinolone können sehr schwere
Nebenwirkungen hervorrufen,
was leider
erst sehr spät erkannt wurde.
Und obwohl
wir es jetzt besser wissen,
kommt dieses Wissen nur
sehr schwerfällig in der Praxis an.
Noch im Jahr 2018
gehörten Fluorchinolone
zu den häufig verschriebenen
Antibiotika in Deutschland.
Immer noch tragen wahrscheinlich
zehntausende Menschen
unnötigerweise diese schweren
Nebenwirkungen mit sich herum.
Und natürlich riskieren wir
durch den regen Einsatz
die Bildung von Resistenzen.
Was Fluorchinolone wirkungslos
machen könnte für Patienten,
die sonst
keine andere Alternative hätten.
Z.B. Patienten, die unter
einer Bakterien-Infektion leiden,
deren Bakterien
bereits resistent sind
gegen verträglichere Antibiotika.
Auch unsere Haustiere bekommen
unnötig oft Antibiotika verschrieben.
Schon heute
sterben pro Jahr in Europa
33.000 Menschen
an resistenten Infektionen.
Mein Kollege Rayk hat den Teil noch
von einer anderen Seite beleuchtet.
Sein Video findet ihr in der Endcard.
Das Ganze
wird noch schlimmer,
wenn wir es nicht bald
in den Griff bekommen. Also:
Gegen die Resistenzen an sich
können wir nichts machen,
weil wir
nicht die Evolution stoppen können.
Aber was bleibt, ist ein Wettrennen.
Antibiotikaresistenzen
entwickeln sich derzeit schneller,
als wir Antibiotika
entwickeln können.
Deswegen gibt es 2 Stellschrauben,
wie wir das Problem angehen können.
Erstens: Wir müssen die Entwicklung
der Resistenzen stark verlangsamen.
Was auf jeden Fall hilft, ist,
weniger Antibiotika verwenden.
In der Landwirtschaft sorgten
Regulierungen bereits dafür,
dass der Einsatz von Antibiotika
sich deutlich reduziert hat.
Das ist ein guter Trend,
der weiter verfolgt werden muss.
Denn für Antibiotikaeinsatz
sollte gelten:
Nur, wenn es unbedingt sein muss.
Da können wir uns auch
nicht vor der Frage drücken:
Wie viel Fleisch oder Tierprodukte
müssen denn unbedingt sein?
Auch in Arztpraxen dürfen Antibiotika
nicht einfach auf Verdacht gegen
Erkältungen verschrieben werden.
Und Umfragen haben ergeben,
dass Patienten sogar oft erwarten,
dass sie bei einer Erkältung
Antibiotika vom Arzt bekommen.
Nein, erwartet das nicht!
Seid froh, wenn der Arzt euch sagt,
dass ihr keine Antibiotika braucht.
Geht ins Bett und trinkt Tee.
Dasselbe gilt natürlich auch für die
vorhin erwähnten Reserveantibiotika.
Im April wurden deutsche Ärzte
in einem "Rothe-Hand-Brief"
endlich offiziell dazu aufgefordert,
die gefährlichen Fluorchinolonen
nur noch im Einzelfall und nach
gründlicher Abwägung zu verschreiben.
Doch solche Aufforderungen müssen
konsequenter durchgeführt werden.
Für uns zu Hause gilt: Antibiotika
niemals in der Toilette entsorgen!
Sondern ordnungsgemäß.
Infos dazu in der Videobeschreibung.
Von unserem Wasser-Video
wisst ihr vielleicht noch,
dass Medikamente sowieso
nichts im Abfluss verloren haben.
Weil sie so in der Natur landen.
Aber in Hinblick auf die Resistenzen
verschärft sich das Problem noch.
Und bevor ihr jetzt denkt,
gut, in solchen Abwässern sind diese
Antibiotika aber stark verdünnt -
genau das ist ja das Problem!
Kommen wir zurück zu dieser Studie.
Bakterien können starke Resistenzen
nur entwickeln,
wenn sich wie hier in der Mitte
gegen die tausendfache Konzentration
des Antibiotikums
mehrere aufeinanderfolgende
Mutationen bilden.
Wiederholten die Forscher
das Experiment von 0 auf 1000,
dann schafften die Bakterien
es gar nicht,
solche Resistenzen
auf einmal auszubilden.
Gerade geringe Konzentrationen von
Antibiotika ermöglichen es Bakterien,
schrittweise Resistenzen aufzubauen.
Und Antibiotika
gelangen ja auch normal ins Klo.
Denn wenn wir welche nehmen, wird
nur ein Teil davon verstoffwechselt
und der Rest
wird wieder ausgeschieden.
D.h., gerade bei Krankenhäusern
sind die Abwässer
nicht nur voller Erreger,
sondern auch voller Antibiotika.
Und auch außerhalb der Reichweite
von Patienten,
z.B. im Abflussrohr
von einem Waschbecken,
können sich resistente Keime bilden
und von dort auch irgendwann
wieder zu uns zurückgelangen.
D.h. auch an solchen Stellen kann man
neue Hygienemaßstäbe schaffen.
Es gibt also verschiedene Maßnahmen,
mit denen wir Antibiotika-
Resistenzen eindämmen können.
Für die Umsetzung
sorgen Aktionspläne wie "DART".
Sehr wichtige Initiative,
die bereits Erfolg gezeigt hat.
Unter ihren 6 Zielen ist auch:
Denn im Wettlauf gilt nicht nur,
Resistenzen verlangsamen,
sondern auch schneller
neue Medikamente entwickeln.
Ein Grund, warum wenige neue Anti-
biotika auf den Markt kommen, ist:
Antibiotika
sind nicht wirtschaftlich.
Stellt euch vor,
ihr leitet einen Pharmakonzern
und steckt Milliarden in die
Entwicklung eines neuen Antibiotikums
Ihr kommt damit durch und Ende
sagt die Zulassungsbehörde:
Sehr schön, das funktioniert so gut,
das wird jetzt ein ganz neues
wichtiges Reserve-Antibiotikum.
Es soll so wenig wie möglich
verkauft werden,
nur, wenn es unbedingt sein muss,
und am besten gar nicht.
Überhaupt sind Antibiotika
generell nicht sehr lukrativ.
Weil die Therapie meistens schnell
erfolgreich abgeschlossen ist.
So gibt es wenig Anreize,
Geld und Zeit in die Entwicklung
von Medikamenten zu stecken.
Das ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür,
dass der Markt
eben nicht alles regelt.
Wenn wir die Entwicklung
von Antibiotika
nicht mit öffentlichen
Geldern fördern,
verlieren wir das Wettrennen
gegen die Bakterien.
Auch Forschung an alternativen
Konzepten, wie z.B. Bakteriophagen
oder Antikörpern,
muss weiter gefördert werden.
Deswegen sind in den letzten Jahren
einige internationale Programme
gestartet,
die helfen, genau solche
Forschungen zu finanzieren.
Auch Deutschland
beteiligt sich daran. Richtig so.
Und natürlich ist auch Aufklärung
ein ganz wichtiger Schlüssel
zur Verbesserung.
Deswegen hoffe
ich, dass wir mit diesem Video
ein bisschen dazu beitragen konnten.
Und freue mich natürlich,
wenn ihr dieses Video teilt.
Viele neue Freunde der Sonne dabei,
die noch gar nicht wissen,
warum sie Freunde der Sonne sind.
Zur Erklärung:
Jeder, der diesen Kanal schaut,
ist automatisch ein Freund der Sonne.
Herzlich willkommen!
Setzt euch, nehmt euch einen Keks.
Ein guter Zeitpunkt,
um Themenvorschläge zu sammeln.
Wenn ihr ein interessantes Thema hat,
zu dem ihr ein Video sehen wollt,
also die wissenschaftlichen
Hintergründe wissen wollt,
schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Bei Social Media könnt ihr euch
mit mir vernetzen und schauen,
was ich sonst so mache.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bis dahin - bleibt sicher!
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2019)